[Music]
get ready to dive into the battlefield
and for honor master the medieval
weaponry as the bold Knights brutal
Vikings and lethal samurai prepare for
vicious fast-paced melee combat and
become the ultimate warrior but which of
the three legendary factions will you
choose here's what you need to know to
win glory as the Vikings brought to you
by for honor the Vikings are masters of
the sea they returned in great numbers a
few centuries ago from far across the
sea after fleeing their crumbling
homelands their goal is to reclaim their
ancient homeland valcon high when this
nation of Viking clans gathers in
massive armadas of dragon headed ships
they are nearly unstoppable in joining
the war born Vikings you select from
heroes that are relentless warriors that
have no fear of death they welcome it as
their destiny and intend to bring as
many foes with them as they can you get
the chance to wield two-handed axes a
massive sword or dual axes Master the
Vikings in order to defeat the nights
and the samurai Raiders are relentless
warriors that are easy to use for
beginning players they wield heavy
two-handed axes dealing high damage and
disabling attacks the Brutes of the
battlefield Raiders intimidate their
opponents with heavy swing damaging
attacks and the health to stay in battle
longer than most heavy characters just a
few swings will knock any light to
medium hero out and give other heavy
heroes a run for their money
unfortunately Raiders biggest weakness
is their heavy swing attacks can be
blocked and/or dodged with ease by great
defensive characters or light off and
space characters Raiders combo in with
other heroes or finishing off weekend
foes makes them a nightmare on the field
the Raiders monstrous day naps can crack
enemy skulls in half under their might
warlords dedicate their lives to the
service of the people they are great
mid-level counter attackers slow and
strong they hit hard and sustained a lot
of damage armed with the Gladius and
shield if you like playing as a support
character the Warlord's are perfect for
backing up teammates with balanced
attack and defensive abilities with the
Warlord's shield you can block most
incoming attacks due to the Warlord's
slightly slow attacks and medium damage
it can be a bit tricky landing finishing
rooms however when teamed up with other
heroes in a mosh pit of chaos the
warlord will come out on top the warlord
can also be an effective attacker
against the samurai shego ki will fall
to the might of your sword and shield
berserkers are intimidating Viking
engines of death and is the hardest to
master of the Viking subclasses thus far
they combine close combat at infinite
chain attacks these dual axe wielding
maniacs are excellent in harassing enemy
heroes with quick abilities and the
damage to back it up the berserkers are
a fun subclass to use in for honor as
their speed allows them to dodge and
block quickly however they can go down
fast if hit with just a few heavy
attacks especially from a conqueror
always dodge and time your attacks
wisely since light heroes tire out
faster than other heroes the Knights
will meet their match thanks to the
berserkers war cry to battle and furious
attacks from his twin axes stay on the
move with light attacks followed by
finishing heavy attacks once in a while
and you will be a force to reckon with
on the battlefield
soon we will learn about the newest
subclass of the Vikings the Valkyries
pledge your sword to the war born Viking
clans and join the war of the factions
be sure to check out our other videos to
learn about the other factions nights
and Samurai brought to you by for honor
for honor is available februari 14 2017
and for all your for honor needs stick
with gamespot